hello and welcome to another edition of
famous fridays i believe that whatever
goal you have whatever obstacle is in
your way
somebody has already solved it and the
fastest way for you to reach your goal
is to model the success of other people
and apply their strategies to your
business so you don't have to figure
everything out yourself so today's
lesson is from ron popay who's the
founder of ronco
worth over 100 million dollars and his
lesson is find your strength
and exploit it so here's his story when
he was growing up when he was three
years old
his parents divorced they weren't in
love they divorced they fought all the
time
and they sent him away to a boarding
school and he didn't see them again
until
years later when he was eight years old
he went to go live with his grandparents
but the situation
wasn't that much better he wasn't loved
they fought constantly he was shown no
affection
and he grew up basically always wanting
to connect with people
he struggled on as he was a young adult
and figuring out you know trying to
figure out where he wanted to go in life
and everything changed for him when he
was 16 years old
he was in chicago he went to maxwell
street which is a famous street in
chicago and they had this flea market
that was
happening there and maxwell street
wasn't a great neighborhood
uh it was kind of run down and people
were selling all sorts of fake goods
and he looked at them selling he looked
at them screaming look at how they were
trying to
pitch their products and he thought to
himself at 16 years old
i can do this better and he acted on it
he went out got some kitchen products
brought it to maxwell street
and started selling and he started
negotiating and he started making deals
and he started making money
and he was making more money than he had
ever seen in his life
he was making upwards of 500 a week
which for him was a huge amount of money
at that time
and finally he also found a way to
connect with people and to feel
appreciated where he grew up in the
house where there was no love but he
found his super strength
which was selling and then he exploited
it
so he started off on maxwell street the
next step he took up
was going to work at woolworths and he
made a deal with the manager to say hey
if i come in
and help sell your products will you
give me a cut he made a deal where
he ended up making upwards of a thousand
dollars a week where the average salary
there was 500
a month because he kept focusing on that
one thing he was great at
which was selling from there he went
into tv he created infomercials he
basically
invented the infomercial industry
and it made him a multi-multi-multi
millionaire a lot of entrepreneurs take
the other approach
they start a business and you try to do
everything yourself
right you're you're the inventor you're
the salesperson you're the ceo you're
the copywriter you're the janitor
you're the website programmer you're
everything and as a result
you're not great at anything you can't
achieve
great results because you're stretched
too thin doing all these things that
you're not great at
instead what you want to do is focus on
the one thing that you are the best in
the world at or can be the best in the
world
something that you excel at and focus
only on that
and drive that forward exploit it
because you're going to get way
greater results and if you don't know
what that is yet
start to explore see where
you're walking around just like ron
you're walking around
and you find something you say i could
do a way better job at that
i could do that way better than he or
she's doing it
and then go out and do it who knows
it might make you worth a hundred
million dollars someday too
believe guys like this video you want to
see more subscribe to the channel
thank you so much for watching i'll see
you soon
hi raquel english here with mermaid
junkie tv are you on evan's newsletter
subscription
if not you should be i read every single
one and you should too
ciao
you